foreign
[Music]
Burke professor of Finance at The
Graduate School of Business at Stanford
University and I'm Jules van binsbergen
a finance professor at the Wharton
School of the University of Pennsylvania
this is the all else equal podcast
welcome back everybody today we're going
to talk about what I view is probably
the most important episode that we've
done since we started this podcast
series because we're going to be
discussing the importance of freedom of
expression and the free exchange of
ideas
and we thought that this topic was
important not just because we're seeing
a decline of this freedom of expression
idea in the academy but also because we
really believe that for corporations
it's important that inside your
corporation you set a culture where
people can freely express ideas yes
Jules I can't agree more with ums and
you know what I would like to emphasize
is we didn't have the idea of doing this
podcast topic because we both have a
religious view that freedom of
expression is something that the
country's built on and it's a crucial
part of our culture it's not that at all
we think that without freedom of
expression within an organization the
organization's making a mistake the
competitiveness of the organization will
suffer and that in the end the
organization will be much worse off
without freedom of speech in other words
freedom of speech is a good business
decision and so the reason why I think
it's important that we discuss it now is
that in the Executive Education that I
do where in the last year I've seen
hundreds of different Executives from
various companies I must say many of
them have indicated after me explaining
to them that freedom of expression in
the academy is quite Under Pressure many
of them or maybe all of them even
indicate that they have exactly the same
feeling inside their own organizations
so for some reason the self-censorship
the idea that discussing new ideas and
particularly controversial ideas is
getting harder seems to be something
that is more and more prevalent and
particularly it's more prevalent in the
last five years so there seems to be
some sort of acceleration of this
process where the creative discussions
are not taking place as much as anymore
as they used to Jules I think one of the
important points to understand is that
there's no such thing as protecting
Pleasant speech people say things like
well we should have frameless speech
unless it's offensive
people like Pleasant speech there's not
a reason to protect it the only speech
you have to protect is unpleasant speech
and in an organization unpleasant speech
can take various forms it can be like
somebody pointing out that the way the
corporation has been working for a very
long time maybe it worked 20 years ago
but it's no longer working and since
it's become an integral part of the
culture you saying well this isn't
working anymore is equivalent to you
saying you don't like the organization
and people will react by saying well
that's unpleasant speech we don't want
to hear it well fine it's unpleasant
speech but if you don't hear it the
organization doesn't change and it loses
its competitive Advantage so this idea
that somehow either we only want
Pleasant speech that's just a naive view
you actually want to protect the
unpleasant speech know for sure and for
humans and organizations and those
corporations to improve we need
unfettered critical analysis and
unfortunately nobody likes to receive
criticism and so criticism will always
be experienced by at least some people
as offensive speech so as soon as you
say freedom of expression is fine as
long as it's not offensive we
immediately need to get into the
discussion about who defines what
offensive is under what circumstances
and then in many ways the conversation
is already lost you know let's think a
little bit about what are the
motivations of people to censor other
people why would you even want to shut
down criticism and I think that the
answer is as soon as you start the
censor at least part of the people will
start to infer that you're lying because
why would you have to shut down somebody
from making an argument if it was really
easy to refute that argument in public
debate if it's easy to refute then
there's really no problem you just
refute it the problem is that most
censorship comes to arguments that are
not easy to refute and if the arm is not
easy to refute that bears some thinking
maybe there is a refuge then you can go
through it but maybe it's because the
other person has a point and by taking
that point into account you can become a
better Organization for sure if before
inside the organization or inside the
academy wherever we had a consensus a
so-called scientific consensus but it
really was a scientific consensus under
pressure and the new argument cannot be
refuted then maybe it's time to really
start questioning whether these
disconsenses is any meaning at all maybe
it's time for us to reevaluate all the
arguments change the corporate strategy
change what the corporation has been
doing for the last 20 years and come to
the conclusion that this is no longer
the right strategy I mean you know Jules
we joke and we say that Galileo Galilei
existed today we would reject that the
Earth went round the sun because it
would be in a radical argument going
against every known scientific theory
and people would say sorry you're not
allowed to make that argument and that's
what happened actually when Galileo
Galilei made the argument Italy was at
the Forefront of the Renaissance it was
whether Renaissance started that's where
all the thought leaders lived after
Galileo Galilei
all the thought leaders moved to
Northern Europe and that was the end of
Italy as the center of advancement so
it's a wonderful example of what happens
when you shut down freedom of expression
no I know think about this this is a
corporation suppose that you as a
corporation become known as the place
where people can no longer freely
Express their new ideas and there is
another Corporation maybe even a
different country owner in different
institutional setting you're going to
start losing talent to that other
organization where people are allowed to
freely explore their new ideas because
that organization is going to be much
more successful than your organization
so purely form a competitive advantage
point of view the censoring speech seems
like an extraordinarily bad idea
you know I think the best way to make
this point is using a specific example
and I can think of no better example
then the example described by Michael
Lewis in The Big Short
the trade that John Paulson put on to
take advantage of the circumstances that
led to the 2008 financial crisis
now so let's set the stage a little bit
there was this desire to increase home
ownership in the United States and for
that reason many mortgages new mortgages
were initiated at lower standards people
weren't properly checking the income of
the people that were getting the
mortgages and more importantly people
were getting these mortgages with what
was called teaser rates and so what does
the teaser rate look like suppose that
the market rate for a mortgage is four
percent
but instead of getting the mortgage for
four percent in the first year you're
getting a two and a half percent
interest rate and so it's one and a half
percent lower than what the market rate
is
and people were taking these mortgages
under the assumption that after the
teaser period was over they could simply
refinance the mortgage and get a new
mortgage at a new teaser rate
so they were getting the mortgage
assuming the payment was set at the
lower rate even though they knew that if
the payment reset to the higher rate
they wouldn't be able to afford the home
and they would default
so now the question is what assumptions
are being made and what can go wrong if
people take these mortgages under these
conditions
well the two things that could upset the
apple card as it were what is if
interest rates went up then after a year
the people went to refinance but the new
teaser rate wouldn't be two and a half
percent it would be some number higher
than two and a half percent and at that
rate they couldn't afford the mortgage
and they were defaults or the
alternative is interest rates didn't go
up but the price of a house went down
so that when it came time to refinance
the new mortgage the bank wouldn't let
them take the mortgage because their
house would be underwater so those are
the two conditions in real estate prices
went down or interest rates went up
then they wouldn't be able to refinance
and they couldn't afford the four
percent rate and they would default
but for some reason nobody was taking
into account these two possible
downsides there was a very large amount
of group think going on I think for two
reasons the first one was for many
decades no housing defaults mortgage
defaults had been observed and for at
least 40 years the national house price
index hadn't been going down and so
everybody was just assuming that this
system could keep on working this way
there were even people that made
expressions like safe as houses and
house prices can never go down you heard
this all over the place and I think the
credit rating agencies for this reason
when they had to assess what the default
risk of these mortgages was particularly
the bonds that were issued with
underlying pools of mortgages what we
sometimes call mortgage-backed
Securities they gave them all AAA
ratings that is the highest possible
rating with the lowest possible credit
risk
and when people try to point out to them
the issues the radio agency's view was
that for 70 years the default rate on
mortgages was minute and mortgages
basically didn't default they never
bothered to notice that
teaser rates and uh lacks qualification
standards were a new thing that the
world when it was very little more was
default was a world without teaser
rights and with strict qualifications to
get a mortgage
yes it's a an all else equal mistake and
so what did John Paulson Our Guest for
today do what did he decide to do he
observed that there was this group thing
going on and therefore he decided to bet
on the possibility of mortgage default
anyway
he shorted the molish bonds usually when
you short upon a shorter security you
expose yourself take GameStop for
example and say you think gay stocks
overvalued I think most people even now
think gave stocks over valued
the problem with shorting game stock is
there's nothing that guarantees that it
can't become more overvalued
and when you're short of security if the
price goes way up you have unlimited
downside and you can be wiped out so
generally shorting is a very dangerous
thing the issue though in this case was
there's a limit to how high the price of
the mortgage Bond could go so when John
Paul's ensure of the mortgages he didn't
have to take that much risk so John
Parson went to his investors and said
look
this is gonna cost us one percent a year
for one percent a year if there's any
drop if there's any mortgage default
we're going to make a fortune and what's
fascinating about this trade
is John Paulson waited until the real
estate market started softening he
didn't put the trade on until the real
estate market started going down the
reason why that's a strategy that's
feasible is that there's this lag
between the teaser rates having to be
refinanced and the house price is
dropping so you know that once the house
prices start dropping in the future at
some point in the future when the teaser
rates have to be refinanced that's the
moment that these mortgages get into
trouble exactly and it's absolutely
remarkable that nobody noticed this at
the point in which Real Estate process
started softening what is truly
remarkable is how much money John
Paulson made from this trade he
personally made billions of dollars and
remember he's just the money manager
he's investors made much more than he
did
and I think this is a just a wonderful
example of what happens when you don't
have freedom of expression
yeah when people are so caught up in
their group think that as soon as
somebody poses the alternative
hypothesis they're almost laughed out of
the room people are not even willing to
entertain the possibility that something
that they think cannot be true could
possibly be true and look what the
payoff is when it turns out to be true
while that said this is a good time to
introduce Our Guest which given the
discussion we just had Jonathan barely
needs any further introduction I think
we're very happy to have John Paulson on
the show today John Welcome to our show
let me start with what seems like a
obvious question which is
why were you the only one or almost the
only one who took advantage of the
situation what did it look like at the
time you know I've asked myself that
question many many times and I think
that the first reason is people
basically project Trends so when a trend
has been occurring for a long period of
time it becomes almost a self-fulfilling
prophecy and people don't expect that
Trend to change
secondly they're backward looking
and the range of possible outcomes is
based on what happened in the past
and further
confining that analysis they limit the
period how far they'll look back so
because there was no observable evidence
or history of anything
like I was expecting to happen that
happened it wasn't in their realm of
consideration and they weren't willing
to either look outside of what happened
in the recent past
or consider that the trend would change
why do you think there wasn't more
voices saying look these mortgages are
being issued in a way that they're much
riskier than they appear yeah that's the
interesting thing because I bet with
Moody's at s p because I couldn't
understand why they were rating many of
the Securities AAA
and basically their history went back
at the time maybe 50 years
which would bring you back to 57. they
didn't look pre-World War
two or or down to the Great Depression
so when that time period in the U.S home
prices on average increased every year
there wasn't a an annual period in which
home prices declined on a national scale
so they said that's a long period of
time they've never gone down and we
won't put in our model the prospect that
they could go down
there were pockets of the country where
home prices went down one period in
California and one period in the Gulf
Coast when oil prices collapsed but
those were Regional occurrences that
National occurrences and their models
were based on National Trends and they
were sufficiently Diversified across
regions to get rid of any Regional risk
according to their analysis so they just
were not willing to consider and in that
period also the most recent period home
prices were escalating
double digit for the last five years so
they had a 50-year record they never
went down the last five years they were
double ditched two put in a data point
in their model that home prices would go
down they thought was pure speculation
and what they told me was Moody's
doesn't speculate and they referred to
me in that case as a Speculator
and so why was nobody saying but what if
even if the flow probably Affairs what
if yeah it's amazing they've never been
into fault of an investment grade
mortgage security
so you know they had all this evidence
whole prices go down investment grade
never defaulted recent period was up but
you're right in one sense that there'd
never been mortgage underwritten of such
low quality the credit quality had never
been as poor as it was in that period so
why would they look at a past period to
project how these mortgages will perform
in the future and you're right they
didn't believe the what if scenario
existed it was not in the realm of their
consideration
so John somehow you managed to create
inside your organization a culture where
people did feel comfortable speaking up
and considering this what if scenario so
what did you do and how did you make
that environment in such a way that
people felt comfortable doing that
because clearly you were an outlier many
other organizations could have done the
same thing but ended up not doing that
yeah that's a good point I was not
convinced that high surprise has
followed one up had lived in New York my
whole life I remember in 76 77 following
the recession that were given away home
prices they were giving away houses
beautiful apartments on Fifth Avenue
you could basically buy for nothing
because the maintenance fees were so
high but they went for like a hundred
thousand full floor Apartments
so years later there were several
million and they probably peaked at 30
million and then in Southampton
I was bidding on a house for eight
hundred thousand we went into the
recession in ninety after Drexel fell
this house went into the fall and
ultimately I bought the house
in a bankruptcy auction the owner
defaulted on the mortgage for 235 000.
so I saw a lot of people buy real estate
at the bottom a lot of foreclosures and
then when the market came back they made
very high returns so I thought real
estate was sick with them that they
didn't only go up but people were caught
up in the Euphoria and it's not too
different than the euphoria that existed
in the a bond market last year or the
European bonds how could someone Buy
bonds with negative interest rates the
Swiss you're paying a point and a half
to two points negative interest to hold
the Swiss font was like preposterous say
with German bonds negative yields how
could possibly someone buy a bond and it
seems so Preposterous today but yet they
were doing it record amounts of uh
Securities trading with negative yields
you know there's something that happens
in the bubble mentality where people um
just become blindsided and don't
consider um the what-if scenario or any
other alternatives
what do you think you could do about
this group thing when people do this
because obviously if you are able not to
get caught up in the group think they're
huge profit opportunities you're right
we just recently saw that in the stock
market and the bond market the problem
with profiting from it Jonathan is
getting the timing right
because if you're on the short side and
you get the timing wrong
you can get wiped out if there's no cap
many people lost billions on Tesla I
remember people were coming to me
Tesla's overvalued it's worth more than
Mercedes
and I said how could that be Mercedes
such a great car company globally the
best how could Tesla be worth more than
Mercedes and then Tesla was worth more
than BMW Mercedes and Volkswagen which
includes Audi and Bentley and porch
and then Tesla was worth more than the
entire
German Auto industry that didn't make
then it was worth more than Renault and
all the British manufacturers Italians
was worth more than the entire European
car industry and then ultimately worth
more than the US and European car
industry and then ultimately was worth
more than the entire public market value
of all the auto companies in the world
so as Preposterous yet it kept going up
so if you ever shorted you would have
been killed so you got to be able to get
the timing right depending on the
structure of the investment and then be
able to cap the downside if the Euphoria
continues beyond your expected uh time
frame you know as a society we shut down
people who have different views because
you make these people feel as if they're
stupid or they're idiotic for expressing
an alternative view in your organization
how do you encourage people to talk up
and go against the grave I think to some
extent Jonathan wall guilty of group
think or cognitive dissonance but it
isn't important to have an open
environment to have meetings fraud
meetings and ask people for their
opinions and encourage them to speak out
even when the Viewpoint is different
than the consensus or your own and not
embarrass them or make fun of them or
insult them because they have a
different viewpoint
if it's so important to drill down the
logic of their Viewpoint and see if it
makes sense or they're adding something
valuable but he definitely want to
encourage not
casting people for expressing on
different viewpoints
do you think it's possible to set up
explicit incentives for this or have you
ever thought about setting up explicit
incentives for this that if somebody
deviates from the group and they turn
out to be right that somehow you were
worth them more if not incentives at
least whoever is running the meeting to
encourage different viewpoints and
protect people that have different
viewpoints and provide the institutional
support that that person will not be
drowned out
as you said Jonathan this is stems
Beyond business we got into many
discussions at the secondary school my
daughters went to
which became really intolerant of any
Viewpoint that was not aligned with
their woken
far left few points
and if you expressed a different
Viewpoint you were danger being called a
racist or expelled or penalized and
there was no
institutional support in this
environment to allowed different
viewpoints to be spread since the
administration was aligned with that
Viewpoint and they were not really
looking for discussion they were looking
for implementation
and their goal was not to encourage
discussion but to silence any opposition
so they could Implement their agenda as
quickly as they could
the other area at Stafford I worry most
about is there's a minority that agrees
with that Viewpoint and they have very
strongly about the Viewpoint and the
debt would be fine but where I think it
really gets bad is socially people are
ostracized if they don't have Equity
point and obviously students a large
part of their to your experience after
GSB at Stanford is the social experience
and they live in fear of being
ostracized in that environment and as a
result it shuts down enormous amount of
discussion because they're so worried
you're absolutely right
and I mean I do what I can but obviously
it's limited but what I try to get
across is this idea that it's get into
the habit of looking at somebody who
disagrees with you and assuming bad
intent from them
is really bad because in a business
environment and you keep doing that
you're going to miss opportunities
yeah it has to come from the top if you
don't have a support for freedom of
discussion or support for open
discussion then the person who has the
opposing view
will not be protected for expressing it
and risks expulsion or retaliation
for expressing different views unless
the institution itself protects that
freedom and we all know plenty of
professors students people that have
lost their jobs
for expressing uh different opinions
thank you very much John for being on
the show that was very interesting it
was great to have you John thank you so
much thank you Jonathan Jules and thank
you for covering this important topic
thanks for listening to all else equal
podcast please leave us a review at
Apple podcasts we love to hear from our
listeners and be sure to catch our Next
Episode by subscribing or following our
show wherever you listen to your
podcasts for more information episodes
visit all else equalpodcast.com or
follow us on LinkedIn the all else equal
podcast is a production of Stanford
University's Graduate School of Business
and is produced by alumni FM
[Music]